well the coronavirus crisis is one of
the factors threatening the education of
millions of children worldwide that is
the conclusion of a new report by the
nonprofit save the children
about 1.5 billion children missed school
globally because of the pandemic
and more than 19 countries still had
nationwide school closures due to cove
at 19 as of this summer
the report also blames climate change
for a deteriorating educational
environment
and it highlights the extraordinary
challenges to girls education worldwide
ranging from cultural reasons to attacks
on girls schools in several countries
well children in india have been out of
school because of the coronavirus
raising worries about a lost generation
of students falling behind dw's namisha
jaiswal has more
schools have reopened in delhi
but the students aren't back here
for 17 months now these classrooms have
been empty
instead of schools screens have to do 45
ashby singh has gone up two grades since
he was in a classroom last
he misses his friends
and was disappointed when he heard he
still doesn't get to go back to see them
he had big plans
the first thing is playing in the
playground with friends
enjoying the time and i would request a
school
that on the first day we meet there will
know there should be no classes
and we can do whatever we want
the government has said schools can
resume with the consent of parents
and parveen core ashbri's mother is not
yet comfortable giving it
she does worry about her son falling
behind without the structure teaching a
classroom offers
welcome back
and as a kindergarten teacher herself
she is deeply familiar with the
shortfalls of online teaching
good job but the still fresh memory of
the terrifying surge in cases earlier
this year haunts her
[Music]
during the second wave hospitals were
overrun we ran out of oxygen and
medicines we weren't getting what we
urgently needed
this is why we're worried if there is an
outbreak we won't be able to get proper
treatment
though this hesitation has left many
schools shuttered they are ready to
welcome the kids back
isolation warts thermal screenings as
well as staggered lunch breaks are just
some of the coronavirus precautions the
government has mandated yet both
administrators and parents are not sure
that it is safe to return
we put these all over the school as a
principal sadhna bhalla expected to feel
euphoric when schools were allowed to
reopen
but the announcement has left her
concerned
she understands the worries of parents
about a potential third wave of cases
especially as some experts anticipate it
could hit children hard
there are also doubts about the level of
pediatric care available in the capital
the fear is real because
there's no one telling us for sure that
hospitals are equipped don't worry
vaccinations are available send your
children with confidence they're saying
if the parents allow so the owners
nobody's taking responsibility
it is this lack of clarity that worries
core
as a parent and a teacher the safety of
the children is paramount
for now she is determined to keep
cooking up ways to engage and excite a
class of 40 toddlers through a computer
screen but she knows that the highlight
of her day
welcoming her students with a long hug
is still far away
and i'm now pleased to be joined by
sudarshan suchi who is the ceo in india
of the organization save the children a
very warm welcome to the show we've just
seen in that report how the pandemic has
affected schooling in india can you tell
us a little bit more about the main
challenges they are facing there
so
the biggest challenge is one in the mind
of people the fear of the unknown and
the fear of uncertainty in last almost
18 months more than anything what's
happened is an inadequacy
of appropriate information complete
and therefore
the fear has crept in and in the second
wave just when we were emerging out of
the first wave and getting back
into normal the second wave
or took in a very high intensity in a
very short
time so whatever could go wrong at that
particular point went wrong and that had
further
caused
more fear in people in terms of stepping
out
reaching out and restoring a kind of
you know the old normal context
so so it's the fear of unknown more than
anything else
and that looms much larger
in the context
and in your view what can be done in the
short term to help address those fears
so i think
the only cure
to ills of information is more
information and
more awareness
informed objective
initiatives will help so what we think
is one is certainly children should be
back where they belong which is the
schools classrooms but we do believe
that that cannot happen in absolute
isolation or blindness
or disregard of
the basic safeguards so i think it's
like
how do you say there are two sides to it
one is school
need to be safe to welcome back children
and one of the best platforms to build
capacities of children is school
so therefore we want them to come back
there and save the children has been
associated with government in developing
sops for what could be the protocols to
get them back there and more importantly
the entire caregiving community around
them how to secure them because even if
children are not directly threatened
it's it's the vulnerability of their
caregivers
uh which needs to be focused on so
vaccinations vaccinations and
more vaccination
okay and i do want to draw back as well
and ask you about afghanistan because of
course we have seen the taliban return
to power there it's one of the major
questions that the world is asking at
the moment is what that will mean for
the future of education of girls in
afghanistan
in your view what kind of risk does a
taliban return to power pose to women's
education
actually i would
flip that question differently at least
as an organization
we are committed to make sure that
the girls continue to have access to
education
like always before and we would always
be looking to working with all community
groups and all powers everywhere diverse
across the world to ensure that the
merit of this is seen
and there is a continuity for the girls
education all right sudarshan suchi the
ceo in india of the organization save
the children thank you so much for
joining us on dw news
thank you